what's going on there reject nation we literally
just got out of the batman if you're here if you
can leave a like that'd be very much appreciated
you know we gotta talk about our instant thoughts
and emotions or feelings because there's a lot to
unpack here this movie is almost three hours long
for a reason and i'm still processing i'm sure
john is too we're both still processing a lot
because there's no i think i know what i did i
think i knew exactly one word review this movie
is so different than every other live-action
batman movie that has ever existed if you guys
stick around for some of our trailer reactions
commentary part of it you'll probably heard us say
from time to time i'm expecting a little bit of a
slower film something that's much more deliberate
what surprised me was it is so much more of that
so much more to the point where i found myself
occasionally getting pulled out going you want
to talk about no more lies matt reeves was not
lying my first thought was it's kind of like
if francis ford coppola produced a remake of
chinatown directed by david fincher that took
place in the batman universe and was written
while a guy was listening to nirvana that was my
first thought yeah it wasn't just like halfway
it's pretty spot-on i think nicholas wind in refn
but not as slow yeah speed in half and take all
the synths out and there you go so the story
takes place in batman year two where batman is
more known as vengeance a mysterious presence that
criminals fear but is not quite viewed as a hero
by the citizens but especially not by the cops
this movie deals a lot with batman's position in
the world is he a vigilante who punishes criminals
or is he a hero can he be both so as established
in the trailers the story's kickoff point is a
murder mystery where a popular figure in gotham is
murdered and the serial killer leaves many riddles
often being one specifically delivered to batman
one of the many amazing things about this movie is
it is purely what matt reeves said he wanted this
film to be it's a pure dark psychological drama
and i cannot stress that enough the marketing
team specifically put out these three comics which
was batman ego long halloween and batman year one
it is so much of those comics but also such a 70s
movie at the same time yeah it really leans into
the to the film and and neo-noir aesthetics and
just the approach to unraveling the mystery and
the psychosis that onsets for everyone in
the process of doing that while the action
is good that's certainly not the main takeaway
the main takeaway is the storytelling the mood
the rot tension and turmoil this ensemble
but especially what batman is going through
it has this incredibly executed escalation the
tension-filled build is in a gritty bleak world
where the mood is really captured through the soul
of gotham it's a time to straight up horror movie
but primarily a film noir detective murder mystery
film and in many many ways it's the most pure
batman movie ever made the movie is so cold yet
by the end of it i was also like some of the most
emotional i've ever been in a batman movie like
i did find myself like really moved to tears it's
kind of insidious in the way it creeps up on
you well yeah they let the cinematic language
speak where i feel like a lot of movies and a lot
of batman movies let the scripting and the graphic
novel inspiration speak whereas this one does have
moments that are just tonal and are just the pure
magic of cinema through the lens of batman that
are quite moving in a very unique sort of way
there were so many aspects of this movie that has
a lifelong batman fan i found myself going like
they're doing things i started getting misty-eyed
early on because i was like they're doing the
things that i've wanted to see in batman movies
done before the first 15 to 20 minutes of this
movie is easily the best 15 to 20 minutes opening
of any batman movie just my opinion but i stand
by it robert pattinson as batman i feel like you
essentially got like two different performances
here you got bruce wayne and then you got batman
he is mainly batman in this movie i think it'll
take audiences a little bit of time to adjust
especially to like who he is as bruce wayne i mean
the way he plays batman i think is just so awesome
is he badass yeah of course what's unique though
is he's sort of like an alien observing humans
it's a very detached performance but again that's
a compliment similar to ryan gosling's performance
in drive this character is immensely observant
empty but with a rage underneath that like
menacing coldness it's more batman ego less batman
year one where the effects of year one have really
weighed on him into year two simultaneously it's
mainly a private investigator emotionally broken
and tormented detective portrayal with batman
robert pattinson talks so much about how and in
some ways batman's kind of a freak he's a weirdo
you watch the trailers you're like batman's
such a badass everyone just views him like
weirdo in an outsider but he's an ultimate
badass then you watch this movie you're like
that's kind of a weird guy yeah that's what it
would take he wouldn't actually be the billionaire
like hey guys and then want to go out and be the
same kind of batman that we're all used to and
yeah as much as there is like a clear duality
i thought there was also a great connective
tissue between bruce wayne and batman you can
tell all the parts of bruce wayne that inform
the batman that come with him when he puts on the
cape and the cowl and then all the parts that are
left when he takes them off i thought that was
a very wonderful and you know cold interplay a
really fascinatingly hewn character yeah that
would be a reclusive odd kind of distant guy
yeah there is a distinction but also it's the
most they've ever felt intertwined to me and of
the same root or not like one is simply a veneer
to hide the other like they both feel integral
to the way he plays the character and it felt
quite unique in the array of on-screen batman
and bruce wayne performances that we've seen thus
far for sure it's definitely unique matt reeves
talked about how he really was inspired from like
kurt cobain and listen to a lot of nirvana while
writing this movie and so much of bruce wayne does
feel like okay i see all that inspiration it feels
so like punk grunge type of portrayal of bruce
wayne so much of that performance in his eyes
so engrossing yeah like in the world of the
movie he draws all the energy in and when you're
watching him on screen he draws every eyeball
to him the whole supporting cast is so good
you can name everybody like everybody brings
such a presence and feels so distinct and they
are a great ensemble together i mean even though
there are certain characters that you want to see
and that you're looking forward to they all feel
like integral pieces of the puzzle and everybody
brings their a game like everyone's got multiple
moments that really grab you paul dano as riddler
i mean look paul dano he's phenomenal all right
elements of the zodiac killer elements of jigsaw
and it's a very realistic take of what this genius
high-level intellect killer would be they really
treat him like an equal counterpart to batman
i would say where their goals of uprooting the
corruption to gotham are similar but their
methods are just much more different he's
just as obsessive if if not more and is way
more demented it's just kind of weird how the
trailers hide him so much but they put him
in interviews i know he's like you're not
gonna see his face right he's like we're gonna
yeah we're gonna get to know a lot about them
but i appreciate that they went to the effort at
least doing that in the trailer does add to this
sort of like larger than life persona that does
kind of have an interesting effect on you when
you're actually watching it unfold and discovering
what the true circumstances are on screen freaking
uh selena kyle zoe kravitz definitely an origin
tale for her some of the biggest emotional
weight is most given to her out of a lot of the
characters i would say there's some big surprises
to be had with her you know talks and articles
about like can't she have her own spin-off show
yeah i think she can yeah i'm just gonna say
yeah i would watch yeah just great chemistry with
robert pattinson i wasn't like in love with like
oh batman and catwoman i wasn't like feeling that
like such a weight of romance and the way how the
the movie's going for that film noir femme fatale
kind of quality but i still think zoey kravitz
herself as an isolated performer is really good
and overall their chemistry robert patterson's
strong john chituro's karma phi falcone was one
of the biggest surprises of on-screen presence
here it's like not surprising if you know his
his work but in terms of like a standout character
jeffrey wright as uh gordon you know some people
when they saw the trailer would sort of compare it
to morgan freeman and brad pitt it's not that no
not at all definitely not but but jeffrey wright
brings something so refreshing to gordon himself
of course he has that older man qualities because
of what jeffrey wright is there's also something
that feels more relatable about his performance
but he uses his dialogue like little things like
him going like hey man you need to calm down
like things like yeah yeah little very little
remarks that he'll make yeah and that are also
kind of informed by his very relatable like
what i love one good cop well what i love so much
about her was it really felt like him and batman
were doing detective work together a lot of the
time it can just sort of feel like batman shows
up to do gordon's job and keep yeah here they
they are investigating together and you get the
sense that you are the only person i can trust
mutually and they're learning to trust each other
in the building this is year two of batman so
you're uncovering the corruption of gcpd and
i think the way they flushed all that out with
the world was also really well done as someone
who's seen so much batman movies seen so many
batman shows like a lot of this is very familiar
plot but to still feel like something is very
reinvigorating and unique about this angle a nice
welcome surprise and to not have it be ruined
in trailers either was very interesting to me
and colin farrell it's weird and the trailers i
could never see colin farrell when i was watching
the trailers but then the movie i'm like i guess
yeah i can pick up notes of his acting yeah yeah
exactly it's like he's so immersed in the makeup
and the character itself so you can lose him but
also he's got his signature in there andy circus
who doesn't have as much screen time as kind of a
common rhetoric i was hearing when the movie was
done he doesn't have as much screen time but in
a lot of ways you know it's you you could argue
that the heart and soul of this movie is bruce
wayne's relationship that strand relationship
and everything they got to unpack there between
them that's kind of like the heart and soul of the
movie for me actually i would lean more there than
with catwoman i think a lot of people probably
apply that to catwoman as brief as it is it lent
a little bit more to alfred for me in this film
because he's his one true ally in his one true
familial bond yeah i still feel like we could
have used a little bit more screen time with
him especially towards in the last parts of this
movie but in terms of what we did get i was very
much affected by the performance here the music
with michael giaccino the variety that he does
i think in terms of like the genre splicing it's
captured exquisitely through michael giaccino's
score absolutely time to strip a badass batman
movie it's always always an air of tread the
cinematography is as beautiful as you'd expect it
to be very orange the action to it's great action
but it's maybe not as much of a stand like there
are moments within action scenes i would say that
really stand out like that car chase scene they
keep freaking showing all the time fantastic
like in a theater experience wonderful however i
would say that a lot of the hand-to-hand combat
maybe not as gripping or as exciting as even when
that first teaser trailer came out that when it
was like what the [ __ ] nothing quite rivals the
first time you see that you know punch medley go
down and yeah the movie isn't so concerned with
making those moments oh [ __ ] moments so much
as it is about making those moments painful yeah
it just feels like a part of the story and the
style is very specific to the kind of movie this
is that i never found myself just like in awe of a
lot of the action scenes there are some moments
i immediately went to like but that moment was
pretty cool but that moves right yeah yeah they
still get you hooping and hollering to a degree
what other hand-to-hand fights ever came to the
batman warehouse fight in bvs it's not a john wick
movie yeah yeah the hand-to-hand is like harsh
and quick and it's there like you could imagine
it being a john wick movie but it's not shot like
that but that style and that movie for bbs would
not have worked for this movie no no no it's not
the same kind of thing at all yeah it needed to
be what it was here and my only real criticism
about any of the action moments is when he's
using the batwing suit i didn't think the visual
effects in that moment were particularly good
look very cgi which stands out in a film where
everything looks and feels very practical it kind
of had that bobble head effect but it's not that
much of the movie i could definitely feel the run
time of this movie i did start becoming like okay
yeah this is a little long yeah but nothing felt
like unnecessary per se but it did take me a while
to get emotionally invested the movie takes such a
voyeuristic approach in a lot of ways while that
actually lends a lot of weight towards the tone
and the style he actually tore the perspective
considering who batman is in this movie and who
your protagonists and main antagonists are in the
film and the world of gotham i did find myself
more observant and not fully emotionally
invested in the character's journey despite
always being incredibly intrigued however and
i really mean this i don't think it'll be the
same way for everyone and i don't think it'll
be the same way for me on my second go around
with this film because i kept wondering like am i
really going to care about the journey but at the
end i was like oh my god i do i really owe myself
well yeah because so much of it is about people
writhing in the mud and the muck of the mess that
the city has become and all the corruption and all
that and it takes a while to finally establish the
hopeful note and and where that comes from and i
think that's kind of a part of it deliberately
thrusts you into this cold punishing situation
that is having that kind of effect on pretty much
every character i freaking love the movie yeah
yeah i mean like we didn't really talk about it
afterwards but no i freaking love it either yeah
to really kind of start to articulate how you feel
but one thing is for certain when you see it it's
big and scopic and confident and cinematic it
feels planned out to the degree that you know
the the riddler is building plans or whatever
the stream is the kind of movie that critics will
definitely love and i i wonder what the divide
might be for fans this really big wonder the
only real reason why i say this is because while
this movie is fantastic in my opinion it's also
so different than any live-action batman film
and it doesn't quite elicit the same emotional
reaction the trailers do it's much more different
especially because it's not quite aiming to be a
crowd pleaser but i do hope that majority end up
loving it you know i really can't tell if it'll
be divisive or not so yeah guys it's awesome i
don't know where i'd rank it yet but right now
it's a high recommendation so it's a solid batman
out of batman it's gonna take some processing
for some people i didn't realize i loved it
until while talking about it right now yeah
yeah yeah it's not the crowd-pleasing popcorn
movie but what's been so satisfying to me in
this discussion has just been like wow how much
of yeah this feels like a batman film we get to
talk about it feels like the next progression
beyond into just this feels like a full-fledged
cinematic film that could have come out without
comic book source material you know all right
guys well that's it keep a lookout for spoiler
talk catch you guys soon thanks for being here
you